hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to Oh sir the incense
roast me give me your best shot
it just tried to make me weep like the
little baby [ __ ] that I am and I will
read them in the next video I don't know
what I'm scared of though I doubt any
one of you has the Wits to even dent my
ego that was an insult to myself I tried
to make this like more antagonistic
towards you guys and somehow I just made
myself look bad I don't know how I did
that but anyway boesky come on give me
your best shot
give it to me hit me I want you to come
on come on butts butts read this first
what a sad start to this roast still not
a grump I'm too good from BAM you're
handsome I think you know how this works
oh oh oh that's actually good oh my god
Glen's skull has more structure and
creativity than your videos Wow oh my
god mark you have pity fans
you mean you you're a narcissistic
conceited man that uses your inability
to constructively socialize with others
as mean to look cute and gain apathy
don't think you know what apathy means
hey God wait okay hang on
apathy means without even looking up a
kind of like it's like an unwillingness
to do something general malaise lack of
interest of enthusiasm yeah wait all
right yeah like reply boink apathy now
here we go here's a real one we're
getting real why not get real the old
markiplier was much more lovable than
the present markiplier many would prefer
the old markiplier back the one that
does collabs with lesser-known youtubers
the one that could actually make us
laugh with real comedy my best shot here
real
oh [ __ ] excuse my puberty well real
comedy cuz we all know old markiplier
had real comedy I've never shied away
from big swingin balls a day in my life
here we go show that mashed up against
new comedy you you you you you red nose
though but the [ __ ] you as you can see
I'm the same goofy [ __ ] to the hippo
who has been I always will be the same
goofy [ __ ] but honestly I don't mind
this at all I really don't mind real is
good I don't mind criticism to be honest
you you might have been right just a few
months ago but lately I've been having
the time of my life making videos and
have been sharing so many laughs with
you guys that it's been a big bright
shiny ball of Awesome in my existence
it's cool that you're not feeling it
anymore but I'm prouder than I I've ever
been at what I'm making and I think it
shows that's good yes that's about the
best I could
Reles good I don't mind people calling
me out on this I want people to give me
feedback on what I'm doing but it's just
perfectly honest I've been happier than
I've been in years your career has been
in a downward spiral as your viewer base
gets older and out grows you you
desperately try to keep people
interested in more diverse videos or
collaborations but they quickly grown
stale with the stench of overexposure
which will consume you once you realize
your bread and butter is just playing
video games you'll be alone and at the
end of it all I'll still have
accomplished more than you know my god I
don't see how you'll ever quit YouTube
since you're staying a twelve-year-old
prepubescent child this entire time the
only thing that has changed is you have
more pity follows and edgy hair
Oh oh come on you can't backtrack oh no
you can't backtrack nuts too late
oh no no apology in the reply you can't
backtrack it's too late this
twelve-year-old is gonna hold a grudge
against you until the day you die
well you die that sounds like a threat
Dave day I'd I don't wanna sound like
I'm threatening anybody he says he's a
doom master a master would know when the
hell Knights came in to series a master
would know how much ammo he has left and
now is not to panic in front of a baron
of hell oh I'm not a doom master Am I oh
really I am NOT a doom master I hope you
realize that just two generations ago in
my family our last name was literally
doom if someone had married a different
person in my family my last name would
be doom my name would be mark doom I'm
not joking about that either because if
you look up Fischbach I could have been
named mark doom because this is some of
my extended family Murray D doom
Fishbach I was almost named mark doom
how badass with that beef I was they
mark doom holy [ __ ] you're no longer
funny and your cry of fear series
remains your best playthrough yet
despite having made hundreds more videos
since then that's how bad you are and
yet you've managed to watch every single
one of my videos to make that comparison
you sir might just be my biggest fan
ever thanks so much for being the most
dedicated and loyal person to ever watch
my videos
he's literally admitted he's watched
hundreds of my videos and he's still
watching if I'm that bad just stop dude
you've been doing this so long you
forget about the blacksmith the chair
the bee
blow the magic touch etc every time you
think you're finally back on track you
fall off again your promises are cursed
to remain broken your goal is constantly
drifting just out of reach and no matter
what you do you can never quite grasp it
you always fall short said a short joke
a [ __ ] joke also you never put enough
Finn's bra
you're a [ __ ] sellout your videos
used to appeal to a more mature audience
but you since become the face of
youtubers that make fart jokes for
14-year olds you can make as many videos
as you want as the screamy smiley
red-haired icon that your fans think you
are but we can see that when no one is
looking you find yourself alone in a
very dark place you're sad and we can
all tell you better not not be spying on
me and my my masturbation corner that's
supposed to be private you picked up you
spying on me in my lonely masturbation
corner dear markiplier or should I say
dear fake applier you're nice to your
friends on camera but off camera eh
you're just like every other American
and Narses on our cast Cystic [ __ ]
who thinks they own the world
you're only friends with Jax epic I and
PewDiePie they accuse they can support
you with subs and your friends would
rather live in a shoebox then deal with
you you we're probably one of the people
who voted for Trump do be press a dent
PS its Prime Minister Canada al you
didn't need to say that you were
Canadian I could tell by the grammar
love you good your compassion and
selflessness were birthed by your
abandonment issues as a child YouTube
and charity is your coping mechanism to
try and give yourself a feeling of
self-worth which you still do to this
day lack you will never be happy with
yourself or your achievements and will
never fill that empty void
I'm not sure about this one but I
complimented me there so thank you very
much
I'll keep shoving I'll keep doing great
things to fill that gaping hole in me Oh
Oh your comedy is based off of jokes
that a thirteen-year-old would laugh at
you have no confidence in yourself
unless you're in front of a camera
you're given awards that would be the
same as a millennial receiving a
participation reward and your hair is
starting to turn gray
made you look wait are you trying to
tell me that my taco trophy the one that
was given to me by Rachael Ray herself
for making the best margarita at the
YouTube summit is just a participation
award are you kidding
and uh no my hair is not turning gray
I'm not jacksepticeye you once were
really funny your game playthroughs were
great you laughed at all the Roosters
you rolled with all the hate market
lawyers our man is what your fans would
cheer but now they've all got real jobs
they've got real lives I fear now you're
here on Facebook asking for a roast to
make content for videos I suggest that
you don't post we all grow up at some
point we move on to better things but
you Oh mark are immature yet live the
life of kings people say things they
don't mean and some simply post first
but you my friend
I must confess as a comic are the worst
that was actually pretty good I got
nothing to say about that one that was
actually just really good I've got no
snarky reply to this one it was just
plain old good I love it all right okay
so anyway that is all I have time for
right now somehow I went into this
expecting that I was gonna play Oh sir
insult simulator but then I just started
reading you guys's comments for an hour
and ten minutes that was so much fun and
literally honestly guys don't take any
of this personally I mean obviously
some real criticism in here and I
consider it all and I'm happy to get
criticism I've never said that everyone
has to love my videos I actually don't
care if people hate them that's their
right that's totally fine I'll keep
doing what I keep doing because I love
doing what I keep doing I love making
videos I love doing random [ __ ] for
you guys
and I have the greatest time doing it I
have the greatest job in the world
so thank you everybody so much for
watching thank you for all your roasts
if you want to roast me down in the
comments below bring it on
I'd barely shut it here and everyone
knows how easily I cry so give me your
worst I'm ready so thank you everybody
so much for watching and as always I
will see you in the next video